hey everyone and welcome to nostalgia
trip the show where we take a look at
old classic and beloved games and see if
they still hold up today I'm Lucy James
joined by tomorrow saying in light of
DMC 5 which you got to play cop weeks
ago Gamescom we thought we would revisit
the OG the stylish AF the other acronyms
that I I'm not gonna go through but we
thought we'd revisit the original Devil
May Cry from 2001
so before we dig into it I think there's
only really one thing left to say
let's rock baby
[Music]
Devil May Cry started life as Hideki
Kamiya is idea for Resident Evil 4 but
when the team realized that the
action-heavy style obsessed experience
didn't quite jive with Resident Evil
survival horror routes it was spun off
into its own new game when it launched
in August of 2001 Devil May Cry was
praised for breaking away from the resi
mold it delivered faster paced and
involved combat a world that felt dark
and unsettling and a striking
charismatic protagonist while the great
game in its own right Devil May Cry is
also known for birthing and new genre
and establishing the foundations for
some of the most beloved games of today
it's not an overstatement to say that
without Devil May Cry franchises like
God of War Bayonetta and the modern
Ninja Gaiden series may not exist
let's rock baby some I'd like experience
with DMC is that I've dipped in and out
over the years I certainly played games
that have been inspired by like
Bayonetta God of War I'm not like the
hardcore DMC fan I'll dip in and out but
I can appreciate it and I do enjoy it
but certainly compared to you I am
butter scrub despite what the YouTube
comments say I am a Democrat veteran
yeah I am pretty good at the game but
yeah I've been playing it from the very
start it's like one of my strongest ps2
memories there series I'm incredibly
fond of and like Dante's a character the
character I wrote looked at him lovingly
because I've been through some times
with this slide and it's been good the
entire time except for two but yeah so
like I'm well versed in Devil May Cry so
we thought we talked about the gameplay
first because I think it can pretty much
split the gameplay certainly have double
micro one into like there are core
pillars I mean so there's the combat
combat I could flash there is the puzzle
solving and exploration and then this
kind of like sort of RPG elements you
were taking the red orbs and you're
upgrading things but also I would kind
of put into that like the way that the
mission structure is and the way that
you're ranked pretty much constantly
it's a light like score attack star
thing that's into woven in it and like
the thing that we were talking about
just earlier was back when it first came
out and this is what I remember it for
its what everyone logged it for is like
it created a new genre
you know this extreme action or
character action or don't you know and
people have different takes on it but
one of the like main not one of my
praises it got was like it's so
different it's so different from
Resident Evil which is you know
waistband off of it feels fresh it's
like fast and you play all these years
later and the entire time I was playing
I was like man this is a very weird
Resident Evil it felt more like a
Resident Evil than it had ever been
before totally and it's like going back
and not even just
the puzzle-solving inspiration which is
very resident evil like you need a rusty
key you use the rusty would you like to
use the rusticate you use the run chain
that kind of thing but it's the way that
like as I was playing it and like you
can tell that they are trying to get the
combat to be as fluid and the motion to
be as good as possible but playing it
now after you've had the years of
previously like the latter DMC's and
bayonetta and stuff where the combat is
just fluid and it's just beautifully
seamless this feels I don't want to say
clunky but it just feels more difficult
yeah it feels angular yeah it's very it
feels you because of the kind of how
government what definitely cry is known
for and the kind of that stylish
fluidity you just assume that it has
that like in your mind like I before I
remember I played this game quite a lot
but like every time I go back to it it
always feels more involved and fluid
than it actually is like when I think
about playing tough might cry one I
think about playing something like a
bayonet you know like you're doing
last-minute dodges to slow down time
you're chaining combos together but
that's the kind of stuff that never
really showed up until Devil May Cry 3
proper right like to had and like a bits
of it never my cry one kind of is the
granddaddy of this genre and every game
in that genre does come after it and
most action games of today all are
indebted to them I cry yeah but it's
more a game of like early ideas than the
things that and that's why it's tricky
to play right we go in there having
played Bayonetta with the muscle memory
looking for like even some glitch I want
to do a roll and in government cranium
bayonet it's like one button back flip
slows down time in this you need to lock
on press direction and then press the a
button and then you'll get a very like
slow roll out of the way what's so
bizarre as well is if you compare it a
bit the control scheme like right
trigger in any other game would be
something super super yeah useful to you
in the original Devil May Cry its point
the game that like I got this from my
cousin like he bought it for me and like
I loved it so much that I was ringing
him every day to thank him for buying it
for me it was that like and the thing
that sold it to me was this moment like
I saw a clip of
Dontae using a sword to launch an enemy
into the air and then just firing guns
at them and keeping them in the air and
that was it like I was like holy crap
and even today maybe it's more nostalgia
being stoked by it I find that still
really really cool just knocking someone
into the air okay my my my my my and
just like they lean into that over there
and that's what like not only does this
game establish the framework for like
how character action games play but also
the style like Bayonetta always a lot
today yeah exactly like and that the
flare and the kind of like bravado that
Bayonetta has the confidence it's very
much like Dante's perhaps a little
cornea in this version of Dante and
Devil May Cry but it is is that same
kind of personality and it's come here
who brought both of those you know you
know bore those characters to life so
it's no surprise that that's happening
but yeah it's it's such an influential
game in terms of gameplay combat and the
puzzles are a bit weird they're like the
pacing of it is in 2018 is is really
really weird
like you very very strange yeah it feels
like they you can see more than ever how
they retrofitted a Resident Evil game to
be an action game things like that the
pacing breaking up missions it seems a
bit unnecessary like you have some
missions which is like run from here to
there and kill two enemies and it's like
you did it good work and then other
missions I like they added that in super
late like in development right yeah and
you can totally tell like it's not just
that it's like a random mission where
you're moving from the top of a tower to
the bottom the tower but your health is
slowly chipping away and all you have to
do is jump
yeah jump it's retraining like putting
it's very change but like I find the
mission structure gives it such an an
also coupled to the difficulty you get a
greater feeling of accomplishment and
with the ranking system as you're going
through it's a game where if you're
doing stuff right you are constantly
rewarded for it and even though I find
it so difficult to play these is because
my muscle memory is so tuned to modern
hacker slash games when I did actually
succeed I felt like so elated like
punching yeah you could say it's the
dark souls of action games no
we touched upon this briefly already
that the plot of Devil May Cry is bad
there is a really cool like parts to it
I find like the fact that he has his own
little devil hunting business at
McGinty's all these skulls on the wall
and he's got this the femme fatale ASCII
character and an evil brother this is
this is stuff that is bad in 2019 when I
first played this this was the coolest
[ __ ] I had ever seen so the thing is
it's like when this game came out the
matrix was yeah like the matrix came out
like 199 but also if you look at the
person who created this game whose baby
it is that is Becky come here come here
this is Hideki career yeah he's
responsible for like he worked on
Resident Evil beautiful Joe Okami which
is my favorite game of all time
Bayonetta obviously so like this is a
guy you can just tell like as he's
writing this game he's deciding this
game he's like this is why I think yeah
it's like you can see the two pictures
like there's the picture of him with the
wolf and it's like there's this cute
little dog and there's him and you can
get a feel for what how economy could
come out of that moment like he's got
this war I love that man he understands
like a connection with that wolf and
that's a big part of you know
Okami and then you look at the picture
of him with his mother in that jacket
with one hand on his thing and you
understand how that man can create Devil
May Cry and it's that level of cool is
represented in in the game and as far as
I'm concerned that come here looks
amazing there like the way you kind of
look back on it and ironically think
that's cool like back in the day is the
same way that Devil May Cry feels it
feels like you understand this was cool
back in the day so I can't like hate it
but like playing it now you are like
it's same with the story same with a
caricature like this is a bit weird
innit but I remember this being the
coolest stuff and it still feels that
way that's the thing it kind of does
like despite it's fun to see ask setting
there are so many different things about
it that does transport you back to the
early noughties like the way some of the
in terms of phrase are incredible in
some of the ways that just the character
the way the character dressed in like
hola
yeah and like Trish for example like the
art and character archetypes Dante
specifically like he was cool this is
what the type of writing that you could
get away with back then and it struggles
to fly right now like all you had to do
to make a character really popular was
just make them look cool and say you
have a couple of cool things and like
this game doesn't explore backstory in a
super meaningful way it's got was like
mundus and him being the son of the
legendary spotter and yellow Angelo
being his brother but that's like
baseline anime level storytelling not
you know modern anime is considerably
more complicated and that flew back then
in this day and age like if you were
playing it for the first time you would
this you'd laugh at it
well like if you have that nostalgia
this is still cool because you know
everything that happens in between all
the other games you know like how it all
comes together so like from that
perspective I admit that it's bad but I
love it
are you honestly like if it was I
couldn't imagine like if those
characters and if everything was so
po-faced and it just wouldn't work you
need camp yeah I think it's something
that isn't like I'm sorry to keep
bringing Bayonetta into this but she's I
mean you know she owes so much this it's
something that when he went to paint it
and did Bay that's it he just ran with
yeah and it's it's great and like yeah
sure if you're not used to that kind of
thing it's not gonna work out me but
like totally it's a lot of that that
camp nurse and like hardness and really
like easy breezy kind of like pacing and
tone it's important to the genre like
it's not just bein air that does it it's
in vanquish it's in like elements of God
of War it's a wonderful 101 it's in like
a lot of the other DMC games as well
most action games have that because
there's such an intense experience if
they're super demanding the f it was
also really like po-faced and dreary and
like that's kind of there are games that
have that and they're games that are
often forgotten in the genre stuff like
Dante's Inferno I think it's important
to have that camp eNOS and it's why it's
been so important to to this series but
it can overstep at times see Devil May
Cry 4 we're not talking about that today
we just talk about the original let me
help let me say my piece
[Music]
[Music]
the impact is the original does my cry
like cannot be yeah I I think the
biggest impact it had was I wore a
leather trousers and we cut that please
[Laughter]
moving on so it's an important game to
gaming as a genre it's like it created a
genre right I'm never gonna find it
either
well after that revelation could do it's
it created a genre and it's a genre
that's been popular and like what I love
about it is it it did this very Japanese
thing to me for me it took two things
that I loved action games character
driven stuff and fighting games and put
them to get us started to put together
in a really meaningful way so this was
like the first step in bringing those
two genres together when I play a modern
action game from platinum I feel like
I'm playing a street by a Tekken the
kind of button demands that kind of
stuff and that as a genre is like huge
for so many people the idea of cool in
video games it's been a huge influence
on and cinematics and and like you know
taking movies and John Woo style set
pieces and bringing him into video games
it was a big like moment in cinematic
gaming and there's modern games now that
like we said a bunch of times are
indebted to it like a lot of world wars
God of War as a franchise exists because
of Devil May Cry it was a Japanese
developer I always come here but it was
like it does it sounds like something he
would definitely block koribo log on to
if he was given the opportunity but like
the whole point is that we you know
there will never be a good Western yeah
that's that's what a Japanese developer
said they said a Westerners don't know
how to do combat which is why God of War
happened
and which is living on today and has
just had one of its best entries ever so
like the impact of Devil May Cry is
clear like and and things like Dante as
a character for example he's enduring in
a way that very few other characters are
like he is one of the big mascot so of
video games as a whole not just
PlayStation or Capcom or whatever people
love him he's cool he's he is Mario of
the sword
the thing about definitely cries like
playing it today it's one of those games
where like the intent is pouring out of
every single part of that game and
sometimes it just feels sometimes it
feels like the game is working against
you hmm because if maybe the technology
the time or you know how quickly it was
developed or something you kind of have
to separate your mind from where
hack-and-slash games are now to where
they were yeah and when you're playing
og DMC now like in we've been playing
remastered recently it's such an
important moment in gaming but it's kind
of nice just to take a step back to
appreciate it then and to see how far
we've come not just in DMC but like
motion and fluidity and combating games
in general and so like that being said
does it hold up today if you take a step
back yeah and if you're willing to it's
more like take a look at gaming history
rather than just assume that the game is
going to work the way that you want it
to it's exactly what I was thinking it's
like you have to appreciate it on its
own terms and in that regard I think it
totally does don't hold up and I think
it's definitely a game that you still
should experience and play now you're
gonna be one or two people if you're
playing over mic right now even you have
the nostalgia and you know all the
faults that it has and you're able to
put it in the context and you can enjoy
it as it is however if you're coming to
it for the first time you need to
approach it knowing and keeping in mind
that this is like a moment to educate or
like take a take a like a trip back in
time and see how this genre was born
think of it in an educational value you
can like it's like the way you watch a
cure now like you watch akhira and
there's so many parts of it that have
been pulled by Hollywood as a whole and
move
making that when you watch it if you're
just looking to critique it you just say
this is a thing that every other movie
does but if you remind yourself as this
is the first time it happened this is a
first time animation look this good this
is the first time a story was told on
this level this is the first time
animation techniques like these were
used and because of this the you know
the industry flourished and and learned
from it
you have a better experience of watching
Akira and it's the same with over make
right if you treat it as like an
educational moment and see that this is
the birth of a genre you have a good
time with it it will still be weird and
at times the camera will fight against
you come back after it rough
oh but still totally still worth playing
in this 2018 so that was this episode of
nostalgia trip let us know your fondest
Devil May Cry memories are you still
playing it today let us know in the
comments below
come find us on Twitter I'm at least
James games I'm at some more H we'll see
you next time
[Music]